Is this B supplement okay for me?
I'd have to look at that.
Let me look at that real quick.
The B supreme from designs for health.
The only thing with that is.
Is that does contain.
Five methyl tetrahedron folate as the folate, which.
For people without cancer that would be the right type of.
Folate and it contains methylcobolamine.
For the B 12 now.
Understand.
I talk a lot about this in the genetics stuff.
But you know, we need methyl groups.
They're essential for us because methyl groups help turn genes off.
That's the main thing that a methyl group does.
And so these supplements that folate is.
And in this supplement is five methyl tetrahedron folate.
It adds a methyl group so you get the benefit of the methyl group.
And the B 12 is methylcobolamine.
So it's bound to a methyl group.
Problem with methyl groups with somebody who has cancer is if you get excess methyl groups,
you could basically be overmethylating.
And you risk turning genes off that you don't want to turn off.
That is tumor suppressor genes.
So remember in each of your cells, you have tumor suppressor genes.
You've heard probably the most about tumor suppressor genes with the bronca gene.
Now the bronca gene families has dozens and dozens of different bronca genes.
And they act as tumor suppressor genes.
The most research is the TP 53 gene.
That's another tumor suppressor gene.
There's numerous tumor suppressor genes.
What do two or suppressor genes do?
So when a cell starts to replicate too rapidly, i.e. act like a cancer cell,
the tumor suppressor genes are supposed to turn on and stimulate cell death apoptosis.
There's some people with a lot of defects in their tumor suppressor genes can have a reduction of that action taking place.
If I have the bronca gene defect, and I have the bronca gene defect,
a defect in the tumor suppressor genes never cause cancer.
But if I have cancer starting to grow by tumor suppressor genes,
if they have a lot of defects in them,
we'll probably not function as well.
And we'll probably not function as well.
I turn it on cell death plate pathways.
So if you use a lot of methyl groups,
you will also overly turn those genes off.
So I don't like giving cancer patients supplements with methyl groups.
That's why if you have a B12 deficiency,
we typically recommend either hydroxycobolamine or adenosylcobolamine,
not methylcobolamine because methyl groups will help turn off tumor suppressor genes.
And most of our cancer patients are eating real well,
are eating more green leafy vegetables than they ever did before on their new diet.
So they're getting plenty of natural methyl groups.
I don't see any reason to be overmethylating this person.
The only time that we would I would override that logic,
if this person was pretty much in a very stable state with their cancer,
they're doing really well and we look at their blood work and they have elevated homocysteine.
So elevated homocysteine,
you want to use the B vitamins and the methyl groups to help with high homocysteine levels.
So if a person has elevated homocysteine,
then I would override that.
And if they're doing well with their cancer.
So I would override that because elevated homocysteine can add here
and ethereal cells, that's the cells that line your arteries
and can cause excess placking because of that etching.
The cholesterol is trying to repair that etching
and could cause heart disease, quarter heart blockage.
So you don't want high elevated homocysteine levels.
You need more methyl groups.
The only other caveat to that if the person was doing really well,
and genetically they had a double allele defect on their two MTHFR genes,
that I'd say maybe we should add some methyl groups.
But even a cancer patient, if they have a double allele defect on both their MTHFR genes,
and they have cancer that's growing, I still wouldn't give methyl groups.